[Musique]
le turbo ton résulte du mariage de deux
techniques très différentes la technique
ferroviaire et la technique aéronautique
en vue de créer un type de véhicule
capable de circuler à grande vitesse sur
des voies constitué d'éléments
classiques les éléments nouveaux cet
engin c'est évidemment la turbine à gaz
pourquoi la turbine à gaz parce qu'il
faut sur cet engin avoir beaucoup de
puissance pour aller vite mais en même
temps il faut alléger le véhicule pas ce
qui importe pour aller vite s'ils n'ont
pas la puissance hull mais le rapport de
la puissance à la masse c'est à dire la
puissance massique la sensation de
vitesse ressentie par le voyageur
dépendant seulement l'impression
visuelle mais d impression de confort
qui sont donnés par la suspension et
l'insonorisation vitesse oui en
augmentant la sécurité
alors il ya un exemple mondial qui est
très important actuellement c'est celui
de cadeaux sur le tokaïdo on roule
depuis huit ans à peu près je crois sans
le mois d' accident le niveau de bruit
de ce véhicule aux vitesses supérieures
à 200 kilomètres à l'heure est inférieur
de 5 à 6 décibels au niveau de bruit
mesuré au même point pour un train
classique
monsieur jean du gard à combien le
turbeauté en travers ce titre votre
gamme en général dans les 300 km lors il
ya moins de déplacements d'elle que par
exemple un terrain avec une pièce assez
à 149 que la vitesse doit d'abord être
praticable sans augmentation des
sensations du voyageur mais elle doit
également pour le voyageur praticable
sans augmentation de la somme qui doit
débourser ces rames seront lancés à
quelle époque et sur quel trajet je peux
parler des projets qui sont prévues il
s'agit de surtout de paris lyon
la mise en service des turbines trains
permettrait d'abaisser le parcours paris
lyon le temps de parcours à 2h et
d'augmenter la fréquence également
considérablement de l'ordre de 30
allez retourne un jour c'est comme vous
l'avez vu nous venons de faire un nouvel
essai qui nous a permis d'atteindre
facilement la vitesse de 300 km à
l'heure et de la dépasser légèrement
puisque nous avons atteint 305
kilomètres à l'heure vous avez pu vous
rendre compte qu'à cette vitesse le
comportement de la ram et la suspension
de la cabine la tenue la stabilité de la
cabine était tout à fait satisfaisante
et que la circulation à l'hôtel vitesse
pour pour notre tour train expérimental
est quelque chose qui commence à devenir
de pratique assez courante
monsieur le ministre quelles sont vos
impressions et bien gt2 très frappé de
l'impression de vitesse que l'on a dans
la cabine
j'ai été aussi très frappé de que la
suspension la qualité de confort soit du
même ordre de grandeur que celles qu'on
peut avoir dans le mistral ou dans le
capitole à des vitesses très inférieurs
et par conséquent du fait que j'ai
l'impression que pourvu que la voie soit
adaptée et bien on est déjà presque dans
l'air d'exploitation industrielle de ces
très grandes vitesses ceux ci elle a été
très frappant courbes et pour vous c'est
un art ja de l'avenir c'est un signe de
la vitalité des la technique française
car cette technique n'a aucun équivalent
et c'est une extrêmement encourageant
non seulement pour l'avenir des
transports mais aussi pour l'avenir des
exportations
[Musique]